I don't think a lot of people realize
that you no longer wear Crocs I bought
like 40 pairs of shoes on Amazon that
were all barefoot shoes and I ended up
liking Crocs the most what are you
rocking right now these are some sandals
I wear these because I can wear these in
the most environments because I can wear
these to the gym which I actually really
like I can wear these in water I can
wear these on the beach they're closed
toe so I can wear them most restaurants
and I don't have to wear socks so it's
like what else do you need they also
have a foam bottom like rubber stuff
makes your foot sweat underneath Crocs
for example make your feet get sweaty
yeah feet don't sweat in these yeah
someday I'll make the mosey Mosey
moccasin